i've been uh eager to talk to this man
i've always enjoyed seeing his press
conferences when he was uh with the san
francisco 49ers that's now in the past
tense because he's now the new head
coach of the miami dolphins joining us
here on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line on the rich eisen show mike
mcdaniel how are you coach sir
dude
so fired up
i appreciate it
i i love i love this show i love thank
you i love watching guys sprinting suits
thank you sir every combine i i just i
just love everything you guys are about
i appreciate you saying that um you know
uh
what do what do you think of uh my run
and speed then do you think um um i i
guess i put the wattle um in it you have
the actual one but the real one right i
got the waddle in the run what are your
thoughts on it mike mcdaniel no i i
think um
you you give inspiration um to
millions of
uh unathletic
uh out of shape oh men yes sir the
country you know what
i appreciate that assessment that honest
assessment
i appreciate it
it's my pleasure i uh thank you
in all seriousness um
you you've done a such a great job for
such a long time so thank you i'm
humbled to be here i appreciate you
saying that and congratulations on your
new gig
um and what you have done to to get it i
i just want to jump in real quick here
first
about your journey so you started as an
intern right in 05 for the broncos with
mike shanahan how did you first get
hooked up with mike shanahan because
obviously that started a journey that
led to um i guess this phone call in a
way
well well uh yeah the journey to the
phone call as we as we'll call it um
that that was uh
that was even longer story but there's a
whole story about me um
basically
um
becoming a a ball boy
um
for the broncos my mom
met my eventual stepdad who's the video
guy and that got to me being in college
trying to figure out what i wanted to do
with my
my career
checking out some eye banking stuff
seeing that i wouldn't be good at that
because
passion for numbers was not my gig so
then um reaching out to mike shanahan to
try to get a letter of recommendation
was all was hey can you write a letter
of recommendation trying to get a ga job
because i knew football was my passion
well he
he uh
he appreciated my work as a ball boy um
you know i wasn't a coach's kid so i
definitely worked harder or um i was
just sprinting everywhere sweating doing
all anything and everything because i
was just so appreciative i was a fan so
it was um
a surreal experience for me anyway so he
says all right
i'll do you one better i'll give you a
summer internship well that summer
internship was kind of fake it was made
up it was just you can come and hang out
for the summer and and see what coaches
do
well
i
i kind of
pinpointed that there was a lot of stuff
going on that coaches didn't really want
to do
and they weren't paying me so i was like
you know what if i do a bunch of odd
jobs by the time
and doing well that no one else wants to
do by the time um the season roll around
he'll uh he'll no one will want to get
rid of me because they won't want to do
these terrible jobs and
sure sure enough that's what happened we
went to the afc championship game
gary kubiak at the head job with the
houston texans and um i got a i got a
full paid job and that's how you your
coaching career began and then
eventually you know obviously back with
shanahan and dc and then quinn
in atlanta and then eventually with kyle
in san francisco when when did you
realize um offense
or running and the game
on that side of the ball was your
your area of expertise when did that
hit you mike mcdaniel well well rich
that's a great question thank you know
why because it was uh
washington redskins
and i can pinpoint it it was um
washington redskins 2011
where i just got hired back
i spent two years away um from kyle
and i got hired back to the redskins i
last time i was with him i was you know
his
uh
his understudy and i was kind of the
young
um a quote smart coach or whatever um
then went
to the ufl get then like the first two
days on the job i got hired february 15
2011. and um they were already starting
what we call cut-ups in the off-season
where you're just watching
all of your uh all of your past plays by
concepts in a staff room with your
entire offensive staff
and those first two days were locked up
in that room
and outflanking kyle um was matt lafleur
and sean mcvay
and they were just
i mean
let's be honest i couldn't get a word in
edgewise they hadn't said all the
answers and i was like what is this you
know i'm supposed to be the guy that you
know the young coach and here these guys
were it was pretty intimidating process
so that happened for about two weeks and
then
um then we started on the run the run
game
and the entire time um we're going
through you know half the portion of
cut-ups um
kyle's only talking to chris hurster
and i'm like wow well
um i know one thing that they're not
talking during and that's the run
cut-ups maybe if i go uh get with
you know maybe i can ask kyle to be in
the offensive line room
and if i know that angle um
you know i can i can have some added
value there so it's like a survival or
competitiveness or whatever
and
you know their their esteem that kind of
pushed me in that direction
and you know then i i ended up being in
the line room for two years
and became the receiver coach
but then once we got fired from
the redskins and went to cleveland
um i was the only guy that kyle um took
so i coached the receivers but then also
did the run game and ended up doing the
run game for kyle from 2014 on and
obviously then you start incorporating
receivers in the run game that we just
saw so uh before
so so i guess the question i have for
you is
is what we have seen in the last several
years in san francisco from that run
game from that offense in general
something that you think that well i
know dolphins fans are extremely excited
about the idea that you can take that
template and put it on the current
personnel in in miami mike mcdaniel
well that i think that's one thing that
i'm empowered with is that
the template is that there's no
templates i think one of the keys for
one of the assets that that that i
provide or you know the situations and
atmospheres that i've been in my and my
experience lends me to
is that
um you're always adapting
to your players and
what their specific skill sets are so
um
you know that it
uh with the miami dolphins um
we're gonna be
um
whatever
our our talents provide us to you know
there'll be there's things you learn
every every year but um
and there will be it'll definitely look
um similar to what
what i was a part of
back in san francisco but there'll be
different twists and you know shoot uh
divo samuel didn't run
run the ball from the backfield until
you know week 10 of
2021 season right so
you know that it's it's the constant
advent the the adaptation the
evolution that i think is um
a part of
part of my dna as a coach that i'm i'm
excited to get with these new guys you
know you just want to get to
you want to teach them a foundation of
offense and then you don't want to have
blinders on you just want it to take its
course whatever direction um their
skills fit and then that's
as exciting as a process as one could be
in um
as a coach really so deebo is clearly
you know uh
uh a unicorn you could even say i mean
he's unique special is waddle can you
put waddle on that roll do you think and
run him like that i think i think you
can put waddle in his own role
and he is that he is very special i
think there's only um there's only a
handful of guys in the in the league
um currently that can run as fast as he
can
and then even less that um
that are
able to do so while um while carrying a
football so there's there's a lot to be
excited and i think there's elements
probably that
you get that people will attest oh yeah
that that that's a similar thing they um
that was done with devo family last year
um but there will also be an expansive
thing to fit his skill set you know um
he it's
it's all about
it
letting players make plays with their
skill set he is um
you know
he's got some unique talents
for sure that um
like uh
like devo you know are unique to himself
mike mcdaniel head coach of the miami
dolphins here on the rich eisen show
what what are two skill sets what do you
see when you look at tua tungo viloa
his skills
skill sets other than your ability to
pronounce his last name yes sir
by the way i'm showing off i'm showing
off i'm showing off i'm not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie so many people in my
business botch it like crazy yeah you
know uh
there's
i'm excited about uh
uh first of all i'm having uh you know
just talking to him and getting to know
him um in this stage of the calendar
year uh
he uh
i'm really excited about the the
eagerness and his uh his
his uncharted or untapped potential in
that regard um but on on tape when i
just watched watch him play
um
you know he's one of the more accurate
quarterbacks that um i've been able to
to to study and that's that's super
exciting um you
you don't get the opportunity to
um really even study that many
left-handed quarterback quarterbacks
when it all comes down to it um and but
he really spins it and makes it
uh just
his ball placement his
his uh you know he'll stand in the
pocket he's he's not scared of anything
that
a really good quarterback has to be not
scared of so um i'm just excited about
being a part of his journey
because i think there's there's a lot of
growth there and um the biggest thing is
he's willing you know he's really
willing to do it
and it's hungry and
you know there's a lot of pressure put
on the shoulders of a top 10 quarterback
draft pick um and and you know my job is
to really take that
pressure off his shoulders put him in
situations that he can be successful and
um
you know let
let him accurately throw to uh whatever
eligibles are around them and compete
and go win football games well and again
i know it's not your team anymore but uh
with you here i figured i'll take this
swing um um in the few minutes i have
left with you mike mcdaniel uh is
do you think trey lance is ready to be a
starting quarterback in the nfl you saw
what was going on behind the scenes you
saw maybe
when he did get more reps i spoke to him
right before the super bowl he said he
grew as a quarterback more in the weeks
when he got the reps because he was
starting what are your thoughts on that
subject matter mike mcdaniel
um
talking about the san francisco 49ers
and the trail amps um
not not in the building anymore they're
rich
but
uh you know
my time with him um yes
it was exciting my time with him he
you talk about a dude that was
um
willing and able and
you know wanting to be great that he
himself knew that um there was a lot of
stuff to work on he had just been on a
freaking
long circuit of
you you got to remember these these
draft picks when they come out
um especially ones that uh
you know most of the season gets
cancelled you're just preparing for a
pro day
non-stop for like a calendar year and
then
you after you do your pro day you're
doing more workouts then you get drafted
and you jump into football so it's it's
a grind for them
i don't i'm not sure my time in san
francisco
i wouldn't even know what to say in
terms of that that judgment of it you
started started football games and won
football games last year so you know if
the 49ers choose to um have him as their
starting quarterback um i i'm confident
that's with good reason knowing kyle and
john lynch and if not it doesn't really
mean anything and that
is
you know going to keep working and you
know i have no doubt that that the
picture and the product that i was
around was not the final product so for
me to sit here and say he's going to be
x y or z would be uninformed and that's
not why you had me on the show
well i also knew uh coach that uh you're
not with the the niners anymore because
you scrubbed them from your instagram
account you totally scrubbed it from
your instagram page so i saw that you
know i noticed that well uh
let's be fair yes i'm not sure what you
saw because i've never had an instagram
oh it's a wrong one it didn't have the
check mark that's do you know what
that's my bad um no i've never had one
because my wife made sure i wasn't on
social media before instagram came out
hmm
okay that was a facebook l that i took
back in 2011 so i haven't i haven't been
on i haven't been on any social media
really
facebook l
fantastic uh you know and and i think
we've you know um
uh you're you have untapped potential
coach and and
um and i'm just gonna lay it out there
for you i've had a dream uh with nfl
network
being with the nfl for 18 years it has
never
been accomplished and i i think you
might be the guy to do it um
i've seen your uh press conference game
it is strong it is very very strong
um
however um you know you might want to
just for your own sense you might want
to mix in some coaching cliches i have
my favorite three coaching cliches and
i've never had a coach
complete the triple play within one
single press conference and i think you
can do it
if i give them to you all right
um
so what what's this game we're playing
well
outline it for me so i give you these
are my three favorite coaching cliches
i'd love to see a press conference where
you nail all three of them within one
press conference if i give them to you
and see if you can pull it off what if i
what do you think can we double down and
what if i can pull it off in the in my
next press conference in indianapolis
this is this is exactly what we're
talking about yes sir
ready for them here you go
um
this one my this is number one i don't
have a crystal ball guys okay like
that's i don't have a crystal ball it's
easy it's whenever somebody asks you to
predict the future like for instance um
how how uh how aggressive are you going
to be in free agency then you say well
you see i mean if i had i don't have a
crystal ball right you know as
aggressive as uh
as what's best for the organization very
good that's a good one very good okay
here's another one it's a simple you're
gonna nail this it is what it is it is
what it is guys it is what it is
ladies it is what it is folks you know
like whenever you want to just throw it
out there it is what it is
that's a that's another one
um okay and then the third one is
uh i can only control what i can control
you or you control only what you can
control that sort of thing and then this
is also portable because this is not for
the combine it's for later on if you
ever have a holdout you can substitute
you can control only what you can
control with i'm only talking about the
guys that are here
that's it i'm only talking about the
guesser well i'm just gonna i'm gonna
triple down and say what if i can do
that all in the same statement in my
indie press conferences
yes
mike mcdaniel instant legend yes
yes please that's all i have to say is
yes please that would be incredible all
right well at least i know you'll be
listening oh yes sir i will be in there
i'm going i'm
uh it's the it's the least well-rounded
uh event well i think the draft is the
least well-rounded event of the uh the
nfl calendar i'll be there i got nothing
to do but listen to you just stick the
land this is like this is like this
would be like the triple lindy of
coaching okay like you would just flip
around and nail the whole thing it would
be great so you said you think you can
do this i know you can how's that how's
that yeah and then um
my only request is when i do it yes
mid press conference yes can we i wanna
i wanna
sprint up to the stage high five
well i don't know if i'm physically
going to be there
um you know what i mean like i'm there
no i'm there you make sure you're there
do you know when your press conferences
uh for for the combine do you know
yeah i believe it's wednesday um
one whatever time zone that is okay i'm
there i'm in town i'm going to be there
central book it i will be there and yes
nail it i will i will that would be a
great time to personally meet you face
to face right in the middle of your
process
okay
one statement so i'm raising you all the
time though all right yes coach mike
mcdaniel is accepted okay i'll see you
wednesday thanks for the call appreciate
and congrats on the gig
thanks for the time guys you bet thank
you right back at you same here mike
mcdaniel the new head coach of the miami
dolphins
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here